bientôt excuse et chose d'aussi ont pris
ce constructeur tonnes non il ne s'agit
pas de rasta simulateur ou proches
croient que cette [ __ ] musique
aujourd'hui on va pas être un génie
europe on va être ingénieur en cascade
un métier unique qu'on est les seuls à
pratiquer s'il n'existe pas alors niveau
1 c'est parti donc c'est fait par des
mecs qui ont fait brice quand je te sors
bien évidemment sauf que là il faut
faire des cascades
donc cette fois on contrôle le véhicule
c'est la différence avec abri simulator
on contrôle pas et oui on est passé au
l'abcès des barils explosifs l'étude des
barrettes de fuel à al ayyat la
construction ce niveau contient des roms
a juste à vous êtes actuellement mois de
construction lorsque vous avez terminé
en passant votre conduite ok ça marche
hop et hop
cette trempe pas l'air excellente ya le
looping et est-ce que ça passe la
réponse est non
donc là on va modifier la rend pourra
pas se mentir on voit la dégager n'y a
pas besoin de remplacer gallas a pas
secret mohlala on s'en bat estac ont
fini sur le dos iolo attend il nous est
carrément quoi y'a juste a su le
poitiers et je crains qu'on n'avait pas
eu un diplôme encore ok on à la deuxième
campagne là on va passer à quelque chose
de plus de plus approfondie de plus dur
ok j'en conçois les trois bons on va
voir si ça marche la première rampe
elle passe effectivement de manière très
crémeuse well peuvent se fêter ce nous
mais ça on s'en bat les ce n'est que la
troisième a tenu le choc
ah merde à font passer au sol cette fois
c'est bon allez allez cette fois c'est
la bonne c'est la bonne c'est la bonne
c'est la bonne regarder voila voila mais
c'est ça qu'on veut
waouh ce sera une petite récompense en
tranchée clos mais l'offre aboutie
reggae certain niveau côté zones rouges
dans lesquelles il est interdit de
construire a suffit d'un peu de ce qu'il
a fait en fils de camionneurs n'y a pas
de problème c'est faux on passe là
dessus on arrive sur notre des roms
c'est pas ça passe quand même je pense
et bien non jean-michel simple voilà
jean michel cassé si vous êtes juste de
construire petite rampe d'arrivée et au
mot rigueur est content on n'a pas un
truc pas trop d'ego et où je nettoie ou
la paille
cette fois c'est bon et nous avons
regardé la tension j'ai fait hyper
attention mais non mais c'est un sketch
moi c'est bon là c'est bon voilà voilà
ok on chante l'étoile où chantent les
toiles flocons de [ __ ] troisième
étoile au ski elle est à nous elle est à
nous on a raté l'examen
voilà là on est bien là on est pile bien
mec olalalala made in trajectory ou non
cette fois je vous épargne ou là c'est
quoi ce bordel où commence là on a la
première étoile là faudrait freiné en
fait pour la deuxième ouais on arrive là
hop on atterrit sur cette robe se fait
reculer on passe à travers ça on
accélère on prend ce pont ok là on vient
de faire la route de la mort d'awk la
claque redoublé toile hockey au top
mais sinon attendez attendez chante ça
me prend la tête mais en vrai on veut
juste prendre ça est faux c'est là où on
s'en bat les couilles
ouais j'espère ça s'appelle le produit
en croit totalement faux c'est parti on
est chauds tout doux tout doux tout doux
oui c'est beau et voilà alors je sais
pas pourquoi on s'est fait chier à
vouloir construire de combat mais parce
qu'on est trop qualifié voyez aller 6e
le mélange bien le petit reggae tels
sont les nouveaux véhicules le camion
benne
il est bien plus lourd qu'un dépanneuse
d'accord il faut renforcer la rampe les
poutres d'acier sont plus robustes ok je
remplace le bois par de l'acier et on
sera bon olap et lourdes hausse après
deux numéros en acier avec s'abuser quoi
à quelque chose d'autre chose à on prend
la route pour naguib la life for joy
notre moral est un peu plus élevé la
voix soul x ou y ferme sa gueule moment
vérité moments chocs papa papa papa papa
on y retourne aussitôt en fait j'avais
pas fais des déroutes en acier si vous
voulez hein on est y pas on envoie la
bête c'est ça qui compte
voilà on est bien la regarder ça passe
rien on m'appelle à cheval sur ces
attelages et déjà chantier désolé du
couple au derrière pour le speaker cèdre
en bout
oh what you're gonna do backflip
carrière oui oh la la
atterrissage sommes dit as you know
aller on a débloqué les troisièmes lebel
[ __ ] la tendance à devenir vraiment
dure un mois c'était très dur là on va
faire une robe traditionnelle avec la
technique triangulaire you know why i'm
in c'est quoi ce niveau pour enfants a
effectué trois sauts périlleux à merde
what you're gonna do babe ok suivant non
la cote tout comme ça c'est le bordel
récupérer une seule étoile bon augure
donc on n'a rien on fait ça on shoppe
l'étoile on arrive ici à une arrivée
elle est la merde moi j'espère ça une
rampe comme ça protestons tétouan les
balles restaient ça pète les coûts de
réfléchir la regarder ces bonnes étoiles
et là on arrive là dedans comme prévu et
on tombe sous finale du coup le mieux
ses bottes bronson la apprendre à
l'étoile là qu'est ce qu'on fait eh ben
on accélère et ça passait franchement
n'était pas loin il a vu que la rampe et
plus grands logiquement on peut finir
très utile aux banques au-delà des
cascadeurs un gène y effectuer un saut
périlleux quand même tu connais les bail
en tant qu'ingénieur il faut faire des
choses
attention est ce que ça passe le peuple
de france se demande c'est dégueulasse
c'est sûr ça passe pas
parfait manon aspi pour s'éveiller alors
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire ici récupérer
une étoile le boss a su ce qu'il faut
les malins pro la la j'ai fait une
europe mais tellement belle regarder
vers l'est comme c'est beau ça marche un
pas mais c'est beau on est bien là non
ça se fait de la gueule mais parfait mec
parfait mais parfait olalalala miles et
on a presque fini effectué un saut
périlleux d'accord et fois les all à la
folie ou faux et là dedans en vraie
super nova le faire à l'arrivée la faut
juste passer là je pense on passe on
passe voilà on est passé et l'enfant est
supérieu dernier a tout ce qu'il faut
faire 50 affreuse minutes d'essai plus
tard j'arrive au bout c'est maintenant
ou jamais lucas c'est maintenant ou
jamais
et maintenant la révélation à temps mais
c'est si c'est toi il faut récupérer et
y en a combien 1 2 3 4 5 6 mais avec un
rapide que je me bats les couilles pour
rien dès le début je laissais enfin être
ok c'est parti on va tenter un salto
début histoire deux ont déboulé bon
salto faut juste en face de la fournée
bon mec
l'alsacien dans cette vidéo
j'ai envie de métier et touché en tout
cas ça fait huit ans que sur le jeu
c'est abusé messahel mais ça nous a plu
voilà après notre diplôme d'ingénieur 2
juste et plus quelques on a eu mais en
tout cas s'ajoutent à la liste des
diplômes de cascadeur avec en tout cas
dans certaines branches et nous importe
vous bien car tout le monde dise